leurs familles
je voudrais adresser un message
particulier où 500 personnes qui suivent
notre réunion dans le hall sur des
écrans qui n'ont pas pu rentrer je
voudrais leur dire qu'on est avec eux
comme eux sont avec nous mes chers amis
en ces jours de deuil et de
recueillement en hommage aux victimes
des assassins du pres de vente dernier à
paris parce que ce sont nos mères nos
pères nos soeurs nos frères nos enfants
nos amis et parce que la douleur de ceux
auxquels il était si cher et notre
douleur je vous propose d'observer une
minute de silence en leur mémoire
je vous remercie
michelin a misé sur philippe chers amis
chers leurs amphis andré chaire joseph
daul qui nous a rejoints il est des
circonstances comme celles d'aujourd'hui
où les responsables politiques n'ont
qu'un seul devoir défendre la france est
protégé les français
quand la france est attaquée quand les
français sont menacés
il ne saurait être question de parti de
caen ou d'ambitions personnelles
les événements nous rappellent que nous
sommes au service d'une cause qui nous
dépasse tous une certaine idée de la
france
une certaine idée de la civilisation une
certaine idée de la liberté une certaine
idée de la façon d'être un homme
parce que c'est bien de cela dont la
france parle depuis si longtemps
c'est cette voix françaises que les
assassins veulent faire taire cette
jeunesse foudroyé au fond elle a donné à
la france son plus beau visage
le visage fraternel que les assassins
veulent des figures et en semant la peur
et la haine
nous avons vu la semaine dernière à
travers les témoignages de solidarité
qui se sont manifestés sur tous les
continents
combien la france comptait dans la
conscience universelle et combien il
était important que la france continue à
vivre par les agir dans le monde
en demeurant fidèle à elle même
cette france qui veut être libre cette
france qui veut être debout et que le
monde entier regarde ce n'est pas la
gauche ce n'est pas la droite c'est nous
tous parce que la france c'est un amour
partagé ou le comprend tant mieux qu'ici
à strasbourg au milieu des alsaciens qui
ont toujours manifesté leur attachement
à la france et au delà dans ses ardennes
cette champagne cette lorraine
si souvent wailly mais que rien n'a pu
détacher de la nation
je n'oublie pas bien sûr cher philippe
que nous sommes en campagne électorale
je n'oublie pas les élections à venir où
se joue le sort des régions françaises
est aussi une part du destin de la
france du l'a dit
car l'enjeu de ce scrutin chacun le
pressent n'est pas que régional il est
aussi nationale je voulais à strasbourg
dire mon amitié
ma confiance et notre soutien complet à
felip et à ses colistiers
je n'oublie pas les candidats je
n'oublie pas les élus qui sont ici les
militants qui tous les jours défendre
les idées les valeurs les principes de
notre famille politique dans des
conditions philippe la signaler et des
circonstances particulièrement
difficiles mais je veux affirmer que
nous ne servirions pas la cause de la
france en mettant notre démocratie
entre parenthèses mettre la démocratie
française entre parenthèses serait
donner une victoire à ceux qui veulent
nous forcer par la terreur à renoncer à
ce que nous sommes et assure que en quoi
nous croyons
alors chacun doit s'imposer un effort un
effort sur lui même pour que le débat
public et la hauteur de vue la dignité
que les français sont en droit
d'attendre dans une situation pareille
les circonstances exceptionnelles
appelle des mesures exceptionnelles mais
également
des attitudes des comportements qui ne
peut pas être ceux auxquels une longue
période de paix et de liberté nos
habitués je veux dire avec la même force
et je veux qu'on m'entende qu un peuple
libre est un peuple qui débat un pays
libre est un pays où l'on parle un homme
le libre est un homme qu'il dit ce qu'il
pense
honte au pays où l'on se tait disait
clemenceau il avait raison nous ne nous
tairons pas voilà la première de celles
des zones où est le monde saura qu'en
france la peur est plus forte que la
liberté
taisons nous et le monde sera que la
france n'est plus la france
taisons nous et notre silence sera le
premier signe de notre servitude
j'ai été président de la république je
connais la lourdeur de la charge
conçue rhji le drame je sais l'ampleur
des responsabilités que le chef de
l'état doit assumer et la difficulté de
décider en dernier ressort
seul face à sa conscience
quiconque chercherait instrumentalisée à
des fins électorales
la terrible menace qui pèse sur notre
pays est victime innocente
la souffrance de ceux qui les aimaient
ne serait pas digne de la confiance des
français
mais le silence non plus ne serait pas
digne quand l'intérêt général exige que
l'on parle parler parler d'abord pour
approuver quand les mesures sont
susceptibles de rendre la france plus
forte face à ceux qui veulent la
détruire
j'approuve l'état d'urgence j'approuve
la déchéance de nationalité pour les
binationaux qui ont trahi
la france jacques rose l'assignation à
domicile japon les pouvoirs
exceptionnels donnés aux gouvernements
aux préfets aux autorités
administratives à la police la
gendarmerie pour traquer les assassins
ceux qui les manipulent et ceux qui les
armes
ce n'est pas la police ce n'est pas la
gendarmerie qui menace nos libertés
ce sont les trafiquants ce sont des
fanatiques ce sont les criminels ce sont
les terroristes
ce sont les voyous qui menace nos
libertés cette vérité doit être affirmée
japon
l'accroissement des effectifs de la
police de la gendarmerie de nos armées
c'est devenu nécessaire mais recruter
former c'est long trop long
dans ces conditions les premiers
renforts n'arriveront pas avant deux
voire trois années mobiliser les
réserves de la police de la gendarmerie
de l'armée ce serait plus rapide plus
efficace mettant immédiatement la
disposition des pouvoirs publics des
milliers d'agents et de soldats
expérimentés immédiatement opérationnel
c'est mon devoir de le dire parce qu'il
en va de la sécurité des français
la surveillance plus étroite de ceux qui
sont signalés comme ayant des liens avec
des milieux radicaliser est susceptible
de passer à l'acte les peines de sûreté
pour ceux qui présentent encore un
danger pour la société sont deux
décisions absolument majeur qui ne
peuvent plus être reportée sans faire
courir aux français et risque que
personne n'a le droit de leur faire
courir
c'est mon devoir de le demander je veux
dire avec gravité que nous avons déjà
trop attendu pour mettre en place l'état
d'urgence trop attendu pour donner à la
police et à la gendarmerie
les moyens de démanteler les trafics
d'armes de guerre pour entraver la
circulation des terroristes pour châtier
ceux qui défient la démocratie parce
qu'il la croit faible
trop attendu pour tirer dans tant de
domaines les leçons des attentats du
mois de janvier dernier
ces attentats de janvier aurait dû nous
conduire à agir plus tôt puisque ceux
qui regardaient toute politique
sécuritaire comme à tentatrice aux
libertés ont enfin compris que la
défense de la liberté était un combat
qu'il fallait se donner les moyens de
gagner alors dont nous ses moyens tout
de suite
n'attendons plus nous n'avons pas le
temps car qui oserait cher philippe ici
à strasbourg prendre le risque de dire
qu'il n'ya plus de risque
c'est mon rôle de chef de l'opposition
cher laurent émond de voir d'anciens
chefs de l'état de le dire gouverner
c'est le devoir du président de la
république et du gouvernement soutenir
tout ce qui renforce la sécurité des
français et dénoncer tout ce qui
affaiblit la france dans le combat
qu'elle livre à ceux qui veulent la
détruire c'est le devoir de l'opposition
chacun d'entre nous mes chers amis ne
doit avoir pour seul souci que de
protéger les français et non de marquer
je ne sais quel point dérisoire dans le
combat politique c'est mon rôle c'est
mon devoir
de dire en votre nom à tous à ceux qui
exercent les plus lourdes
responsabilités que dans les
circonstances actuelles où le sort du
pays est entre leurs mains ils ne
seraient pas dignes ni à la hauteur des
événements de chercher attendre à
l'opposition des pièges politiques
c'est aussi mon rôle et mon devoir de
dire à l'opposition républicaine jo sans
naïveté mais en conscience que l'honneur
qui n'est pas un mot des modes et nous
commande de ne pas nous préoccuper des
pièges que l'on pourrait vouloir nous
tendre mes chers amis nous ne devons
nous préoccuper que d'une chose faire le
mieux possible faire ce qui nous paraît
bien et juste ce qui nous paraît bon
pour les français
ce doit être notre une préoccupation
avec ce 4 nous n'avons aucun risque que
le propos le temps n'est pas vouloir
penser le temps n'est pas aux calculs ya
trop de douleur pour penser aux
manoeuvres mes chers amis restons au
dessus la priorité maintenant de tirer
les leçons de ce qui nous arrive c'est
la condition pour conjurer des périls
qui menacent notre liberté
c'est la condition pour protéger les
êtres qui nous sont chères c'est la
condition je le dis ici en alsace pour
conserver notre mode de vie notre modèle
de civilisation
tout ce que nous aimons la réponse au
terrorisme est d'abord sécuritaire et le
gouvernement de ce point de vue s'est
engagé dans la bonne direction mais sont
contentés serait une grave erreur car
dans ce combat nos faiblesses ne sont
pas que sécuritaire oui mes chers amis
il y a tant de domaines où la république
a trop reculé
elle ne peut plus la république à
l'avenir se le permettre
ceux qui nous frappent sartre que nous
sommes vulnérables
ils savent que la société française que
les sociétés européennes que les
sociétés occidentales sont fragiles
parce qu'un profond malaise les étreint
ce malaise et dans l'école
ce malaise est dans la culture ce
malaise et dans la justice dans
l'économie dans la politique
ce malaise touche à toutes ces valeurs
que nous avons laissé attaquer sans les
défendre avec le courage qu'ils auraient
dû s'imposer
la tragédie jean-michel d'art sont les
bienvenus nous oblige collectivement à
quoi un effort de lucidité et jean-paul
immo fort cette tragédie nous oblige un
véritable examen de conscience à propos
de l'affaiblissement de la république
chers amis chers compatriotes peut-être
sommes-nous à l'un des plus grand
tournant de notre histoire depuis la fin
de la seconde guerre mondiale alors
cette vérité il faut maintenant
l'entendre des décennies de renoncement
des décennies de reniement des décennies
de lâcheté collective nous en fabriquer
la société l'europe et le monde où tant
de malheurs sont devenues possibles
nous aurions dû ne pas attendre que soit
versé tant de sang et tout c'est l'âme
nous avons il est temps de le
reconnaître
trop cédé au conformisme qui depuis 40
ans façonnent les opinions et masque le
cheminement souterrain des drames qui
nous sont maintenant au visage nous
avons accepté l'affaiblissement de la
république parce que nous avons voulu
croire je m'adresse aux plus anciens
ainsi que les malheurs des générations
d'autrefois ne pouvait plus revenir
nous avons commis au fond la même faute
que le survivant de la grande guerre
lorsqu'ils ont voulu croire qu'elle
était la dernière des guerres de la même
façon nous avons lu voulu croire que
nous ne reverrons jamais la dépression
des années 30
la remontée des extrêmes des gens
mitraille à la terrasse des cafés en
plein paris des guerres de religion
l'antisémitisme hideuse l'europe cher
joseph se couvrant de barbelés la guerre
froide terminée
nous avons voulu croire que l'histoire
ne serait plus jamais tragique que la
violence et la rareté enfin vaincu
désormais tout serait réglé par quoi par
le marché et par la démocratie le
nouveau credo consistait à promouvoir
l'individu contre la société
le local contre la nationale
l'effritement de l'espace public contre
le privé
mes chers amis l'occident savent bla sur
sa puissance alors qu'ils reculaient
déjà sur la scène du monde sans même
s'en apercevoir
l'occident s'aveugle assure la solidité
de ses valeurs et de ses institutions
alors que déjà elle vacillait l'occident
si lise yona sur sa capacité de
résistance à tous qui lui étaient
hostiles dans le monde alors que
celle-ci en fait s'affaiblissait jour
après jour l'occident n'a pu ou n'a pas
voulu voir que sous les apparences du
progrès matériel il devenait plus
fragiles et plus vulnérables l'occident
resta sio aux quelques voix qui
s'élevaient pensons à ce génie steen et
qui lui rappelaient une vérité éternelle
la civilisation mes chers amis ne peut
pas être seulement matérielle les hommes
pour vivre et simplement pour rester
humains ont besoin de croire et
d'espérer les peuples pour être des
acteurs de leur propre histoire
on besoin d'une transcendance ont besoin
de l'adhésion un idéal plus grand que
l'addition des intérêts de chacun nous
avions oublié cette permanence mais
puisque l'histoire était finie nous
disait qd on est bien les leçons de
l'histoire n'avait plus d'importance
le sacré fut récusé la raison aussi la
morale la science la religion recule air
devant le relativisme qui affirmait que
12 valais la culture bâtie par tous en
retraite devant l'utilitarisme qui
demandait à tous les arts à la
littérature à la poésie à la musique
mais à quoi il servait au lieu
d'apprendre à nos enfants à aimer la
littérature la peinture la musique la
culture et les arts à ceux qui prenaient
la parole pour tenter d'éveiller les
consciences sur les dangers de ce qui
n'est rien d'autre qu'un désarmement
intellectuelles culturelles spirituelles
morales il fut intenté un procès en
sorcellerie ceux qui dénonçaient les
méfaits philippe du pédagogisme à
l'école était disqualifié et dénoncé
comme réactionnaire ce qui rappelait
qu'il n'ya pas d'éducation sans règles
et sans sanctions étaient tenues rien
moins que pour des parents indignes
ce qu'ils qualifiaient et qui défend des
la famille était dénoncée comme petit
bourgeois ceux qui disaient qu'un pays a
besoin de frontières étaient pessimistes
ceux qui évoquaient l'immigration comme
un problème était raciste
ce qu'ils appelaient un islam de france
et qui dénonçait les dangers du
communautarisme et est islamophobe ceux
qui réclamaient que nos enfants
apprennent l'histoire de france à
l'école dans sa chronologie qui prend
elle risque peut découvrir la cohésion
du pays
l'affaissement de son identité
national qui voulait que fut créé une
maison de l'histoire de france étaient
devenus des nationalistes bénigne que
promoteur de guerre les partisans d'une
justice plus ferme avec les délinquants
les défenseurs de l'autorité était
traité rien moins que de fascistes par
des gens qui employait des mots montrant
leur ignorance abyssale de l'histoire du
continent européen
et même mêmes
il se souvient de tel mépris furent
accablé jaffa bien ceux qui osaient a
critiqué la stratégie de l'euro
surévalué
mes chers amis je vous demande votre
attention sur ce point tant de débats
interdits tant de débats et tout fait
dans deux débats impossible quand il
aurait fallu au contraire discuter
approfondir argumenté réfléchir ensemble
à toutes les conséquences de nos choix
collectifs quand il aurait fallu compte
de tous les avertissements
quand il avait fallu penser à toutes les
alertes qui n'ont pas manqué s'agissant
de la voie périlleuse sur laquelle
s'engager pas simplement la france notre
continent et notre civilisation sur un
terrain préparé de longue date par une
génération de penseurs appartenant à
l'espèce si influente de ce auquel cas
nous reprocher de n'avoir jamais placé
que leurs fauteuils dans le sens de
l'histoire
l'occident oubliant tout cela ça dans
une entreprise de table rase dont nous
commençons à peine à mesurer l'ampleur
des conséquences effroyables georges
pompidou disait avec sagesse qu un pays
n'est pas une page blanche et bien un
courant de pensée dominant dans la
politique parfois dans l'enseignement
dans certains cet intellectuel a cherché
au contraire imposer l'idée
qu'il fallait effacer tout ce qui avait
été écrit par les générations qui nous
avaient précédé sur cette page blanche
plus de nation plus l'état plus de
frontières plus d'identité plus la tâche
plus d'héritage ce n'est en revendiquer
préparer d'un catastrophe plus de
devoirs à l'école plein de notes plus de
placement plus de discipline et la
morale legs d'une vieille sagesse
humaine effacées elles aussi au profit
de quoi d'une éthique bricoler en
fonction des circonstances
pour satisfaire aux exigences d'une
prétendue bien pensants ce nom ne dira
jamais à quel point jamais
la folle idéologie de la page blanche a
ouvert la voie à tous les appétits à
tous les égoïsmes à tous les compliments
à tous les sectarismes à toutes les
revendications et engendrer quoi
l'affaissement de la république
ironie de l'histoire c'est sur notre
vieux continent parmi nos vieilles
nations dans notre vieux pays que les
coups les plus durs ont été portées
contre tous les héritages de ses choix
qui nous ont conduits au désordre que
nous redoutons temps aujourd'hui je vous
demande votre attention encore une fois
la mondialisation fut le prétexte
l'europe l'instrument la démocratie la
libé et la république la victime
la mondialisation le fait majeur de
notre époque
la mondialisation qui permet de s'ouvrir
les uns aux autres
la modélisation qui permet de se
rencontrer d'échanger de partager la
mondialisation peut être la meilleure
des choses
goethe entre les hommes les peuples et
société les cultures des pauses
innombrables et arrachant des pans
entiers de l'humanité à la misère il ne
s'agit pas d'en contester des avantages
incontestables mais de voir avec
lucidité que la mondialisation peut
devenir la pire des choses
si elle signifie l'aplatissement
culturelles du monde dont nous voulons à
aucun prix je le dis en alsace parce
qu'ici plus encore qu'ailleurs
l'aplatissement culturel serait
insupportable
la mondialisation c'est la pire des
choses
si ça veut dire déracinement car il n'y
a pas de pire stratégie que le
déracinement l'uniformisation des modes
de vie dont nous ne voulons pas
l'uniformisation des modes de pensée de
création et la mondialisation c'est la
pire des choses
si elle n'est que la porte ouverte à
tous les dom ping et à toutes les
concurrences déloyales et à toutes les
spéculations qui détruisent des emplois
sur le territoire national au profit de
quoi au profit de l'appât du gain
présenter la mondialisation comme cela a
été fait souvent si souvent comme une
force irrésistible devant laquelle tout
doit plier à laquelle chacun doit
s'adapter au fond disons les choses lui
chacun doit se soumettre
quitte à renoncer à ce qu'il est sans
jamais qu'il soit possible d'ouvrir un
débat n'a fait qu'alimenter un rejet de
plus en plus fort ses preuves partout
cher joseph en europe
la révolte des peuples on peut quand
même pas être insensible à la révolte
des peuples européens je suis européen
je mourrai l'idéal européen a toujours
été le mien mais j'entends la révolte
des peuples affirmé que la
mondialisation ne pouvait être heureuse
et que par conséquent les politiques
dont elle est elle prétexte pour mettre
à bas tous les modèles nationaux chacun
hérité d'une histoire
exprimant une sensibilité particulière
ne pourrait être que bénéfique fut une
faute car en signifiant par là même
qu'il n'y avait plus le choix on a
indiqué au peuple que la politique ne
pouvait plus rien s'il ya plus de choix
à quoi sert la politique si le politique
devient impuissant
quelle est la légitimité du politique si
la mondialisation fut le prétexte la
table rase l'europe en fut l'instrument
nous avons voulu construire l'union
européenne
parce que nous voulions avoir un
instrument pour défendre dans le monde
notre idée commune de la civilisation
que deux guerres atroces
la solution finale et les totalitarismes
avaient bien failli anéantir européen je
suis européen je finirai mais trop long
dans mes chers amis nous avons rêvé de
cette europe idéal et nous nous
réveillons brusquement avec une autre
europe s'y acharner à gommer une grande
partie de l'histoire européenne qu'elle
a réussi à ressusciter les vieux démons
nationalistes dont elle était censée
interdire leur tour si on ne voit pas
cela alors c'est qu'on ne regarde pas la
même situation
loin de nous protéger chercheurs cette
europe
désunie désarmé sans volonté nous a
rendus plus vulnérables si général de
gaulle avait raison de dire que la
politique doit se faire à partir des
réalités et bien la grande erreur de
l'europe depuis les années 80 jusqu'à
présent vice vouloir se construire
contre ces réalités nous commencerons
ppri à chaque crise nous créions europe
europe comme s'il s'agissait d'une
formule magique capable à elle seule de
conjurer le sort des remises en cause
aucune schengen ne fonctionne pas on
continue le statut du travailleur
détachées est un scandale
on continue la politique sans limites de
la concurrence est une aubaine pour tous
les prédateurs du monde
on continue nos partenaires ne veulent
pas payer pour une défense européenne
on continue à payer pour eux
l'élargissement et déraisonnable eh bien
on continue à élargir la turquie dans
l'europe c'est irresponsable
eh bien on continue à promettre à la
pureté l'adhésion à l'europe
3 3 que l'on va faire plier la russie en
lui imposant des sanctions est une folie
eh bien on continue à sanctionner
l'europe des chers amis chers et est
toujours mon idéal et le restera mais
parce que l'europe et monde idéal je
refuse que l'europe devienne
l'instrument de nos renoncements par le
biais de règles de normes de
jurisprudence communautaire auquel plus
personne ne comprend rien voilà un
message
q votre souverain
alors le moment est venu de refonder
l'europe le moment c'est en outre elle
est tenue d'avoir les débats que nous
n'avons pas su avoir et de tirer les
leçons de l'histoire récente aux regarde
ce qui s'est passé en 2008 au moment de
la crise financière de ce qui s'est
passé avec la crise grecque de ce qui se
passe avec la crise des réfugiés syriens
et puis se passe avec le terrorisme la
mondialisation comme prétexte l'europe
comme instrument la démocratie comme
alibi que n'at-on dix ans sont en
détruire l'autorité
c'était la démocratie non c'était de la
faiblesse effacer les frontières
c'était la démocratie non c'était un
contresens historique brader le bac pour
le donner à tout le monde
c'était la démocratie non c'était de la
démagogie
faire entrer tout le monde à
l'université sans se soucier des
capacités de chacun c'était la
démocratie non c'était un mensonge
qu'une génération va payer par le
chômage voilà la réalité
l'égalitarisme
c'était la démocratie non c'était de
l'injustice le communautarisme
c'était la démocratie et le respect des
libertés individuelles non c'était les
prémices de la destruction de notre
société qui doit combattre matin midi et
soir un communautarisme dont nous ne
voulons pas sur le territoire de la
république
le multiculturalisme ce qu'est la
démocratie non le multiculturalisme
c'est le contraire de l'identité
nationale française
la judiciarisation de la politique de
l'économie et de la société
c'était la démocratie non c'était le
triomphe d'un immobilisme qui ne veut
pas dire son nom contre tous ceux qui
voulait entreprendre créer innover et
prendre des initiatives
les attaques contre les professions
réglementées contre les notaires contre
les médecins contre les pharmaciens
contre les avocats
c'était la démocratie non c'était la
volonté d'en finir avec un modèle
français fondé sur une déontologie
exigeante et fondée sur l'amour de ces
professionnels pour leur travail
voilà la vérité tant de désastreuse
réforme de l'éducation nationale
c'était la démocratie non c'était la
fascination pour le nivellement
à chaque fois que l'on détruise est
quelque chose c'était au nom de la
démocratie et c'est ainsi que la
politique de la table rase a fini par
mettre en danger la démocratie elle-même
et par détruire un peu plus chaque jour
notre modèle républicain
le communautarisme le sens absolument
inacceptable au 21ème siècle ont fait
aux femmes dans certains quartiers la
politique des quotas dans certaines
écoles les attaques portées contre
l'élitisme républicain la suppression
des classes bilangues le refus de
récompenser le mérite
le refus de reconnaître l'effort le
travail
l'abandon de la simulation les pages
dans l'unité dont l'indivisibilité de la
nation
la loi qui n'est plus appliquée le recul
de l'égalité des chances auquel a
conduit la défaillance de l'école la
dérive de certains quartiers le
sentiment profond d'abandon d'un monde
rural qui se désespèrent parce qu'il est
oublié et parce qu'il est humiliée
l'insécurité culturel l'insécurité
identitaire qui s'ajoute à l'insécurité
économique et social sont les signes les
plus visibles de l'effritement notre
modèle républicain
sous la violence des coups qui lui sont
portés alors mes chers amis les
circonstances nous font un devoir un
devoir de réagir avant d'avoir dilapidé
à jamais le trésor de civilisation et de
culture que nous ont légué les
générations qui nous ont précédés et qui
ont fait de la france pourtant d'homme
le plus beau pays du monde
nous devons sans vince résonne
nous devons faire la guerre à l'état
islamique en l'appelant d'abord par son
nom comment peut-on faire la guerre à
quelqu'un qu'on ne désigne pas c'est
l'état islamique par tous les moyens
sinon le chaos gagnera encore du terrain
la crise des réfugiés déstabilisera
l'europe et le terrorisme continuera de
s'abreuver à cette source empoisonné
mais nous ne cesserons pas d'être
vulnérable aux terribles désordre du
monde
si nous leur posons que des pouvoirs de
police et des pompes
nous devons être capable de leur poser
aussi une unité une grille ions une
solidarité fondée sur une espérance
commune fondée j'ose le mot sur une
fierté partagée d'être les citoyens d'un
grand pays qu'a rendu de grands services
à l'humanité dans ce moment de doute
dans ce moment d'angoissé une solide et
dur nous guider rendre aux français
quelles que soient leurs croyances
quelles que soient leurs origines
quelles que soient leurs histoires
personnelles
le rendent la france de toujours que
nous n'acceptons pas de voir disparaître
la france de toujours dans mon esprit
elle n'est pas immuable la france de
toujours qui n'est pas immobile tv qui
change qui s'enrichit de tout ce qu'on
lui donne qui progresse qui grandit par
la pensée par le sentiment par ce génie
si particulier qui lui a toujours permis
de se relever quand on la croyait a
battu les valeurs de la france de
toujours
c'est ce que nous avons de mieux à
offrir à nos enfants et à ceux qui
veulent partager notre destin nul que
cela soit compris et entendus ne peut
prétendre vouloir partager le destin
français sans prendre les valeurs de la
france à son compte la france n'est pas
un supermarché où l'on choisit ce qui
vous convient
la france est quand tous que l'on
n'adopte comme tel et auquel on apporte
sa contribution et ses sentiments ses
valeurs n'aurait pas dû être grade et
ses valeurs n'aurait pas dû être reniée
il n'y a pas d'identité française il n'y
a pas d'identité heureuse dans une
société devenue multiculturelle il n'y a
pas d'identité française il n'y a pas
d'identité heureux si nous ne partageons
pas des valeurs morales un mode de vie
une politesse le sentiment d'appartenir
à une nation d'avoir une histoire une
langue un imaginaire commun une volonté
d'être solidaires dans les plus grands
succès comme dans les pires épreuves
c'est sur ces valeurs de nous nous
sommes écartés que nous allons devoir
reconstruire reconstruire l'école
reconstruire l'associé
et reconstruire la justice le droit la
politique les institutions tâche qu'il y
à peu encore ray pu paraître impossible
et comme toujours c'est dans le drame
que l'espérance n'est je vais terminer
en vous citant un texte qui m'a beaucoup
touché c'est le texte d'un chanteur dont
je ne partage pas les choix écoutez le
pendant trente ans avec mes amis issus
comme moi des quartiers nord de toulouse
nous avons contesté la république nous
interpellions nous créions mais quand
allez vous nous ouvrir les portes pour
entrer dans cette société
pendant toutes ces années nous avons
oublié que la france était le plus beau
pays du monde
non seulement nous ne nous en sommes pas
aperçu mais nous avons omis de le dire
aux gens pendant toutes ces années nous
avons oublié que notre parole
contestatrice n'était pas censuré que
nous pouvions dire ce que l'on voulait
choses pas du tout évidente dans les
pays de nos parents
il termine je suis un enfant gâté de la
république c'est la république qui a
fait de moi un homme libre je me dois de
lui rendre ce qu'elle m'a donné
en disant cela cet homme fait honneur à
la france
alors mes chers amis les avants une
opportunité historique
j'ai fini de reconstruire jeudi de
reconstruire une nation fraternelle nous
avons besoin d'ordre d'autorité de
justice de fermeté de générosité de
fidélité à nous mêmes et en même temps
d'ouverture
si nous ne sommes pas capables de
concilier ses exigences si nous n'avons
pas assez d'intelligence de courage et
de force de volonté et de coeur pour
changer du tout au tout nos façons de
penser nos façons de voir nos façons
d'agir cher laurent nous ne serons pas
rendez-vous l'histoire or ce rendez vous
nous n'avons pas le droit de le manquer
alors permettez moi de dire devant mes
amis athées côté fne vive l'alsace
toujours fidèle à elle-même est fidèle à
la france vive la république que nous
aimons
et vive la france de toujours
et
à
on
le